>> John Haskell:
Welcome everybody.
Let me have your attention.
You can keep eating,
drinking, et cetera.
I'm John Haskell, the
Director of the Kluge Center.
I see a lot of people that I
recognize from other events
that we've done or the Library
has done so welcome to you
and also welcome, of course,
to folks who have not
done Kluge Center events
and we'll make sure that you're
inundated with information
about subsequent events.
The Dinner and Democracy Series
that a lot of you are familiar
with well this dinner event is a
little bit different but it fits
into our mission where, you
know, we mean to be the place
at the Library where
conversations
and the challenges
facing democracies happen.
As you may know, we do
this in different ways.
We do dinner events
for staff like this,
we do breakfast off the record
conversations with scholars
for members and we do
a lot of public events
that the staff many times
come to featuring a range
of thought leaders
just in the last year
so we've had Anne
Applebaum in a conversation
down in Coolidge Auditorium.
J.D. Vance, Jonathan
Haidt on Coddling
of the American Mind,
and many others.
I hope you'll consider attending
those when you learn about them
and we're going to
have information
on the next Dinner
and Democracy Series.
Those are those geeky seminars
that many of you have gone
to that that are held over
in the Madison Building.
We will have a new series of
those coming up next year.
Just last year the Carnegie
Corporation gave a generous gift
to the Library of
Congress to support chairs
at the Kluge Center in US
Russia and US China relations.
Tonight represents our
kickoff event for the Library
of Congress chairs and US Russia
and then also US
China relations.
Our first scholar,
James Goldgeier,
who is sitting right
here in front of me,
just came to the
Center last month.
He will be here through
May of next year.
Jim's a Professor of, there's an
extensive bio in your materials,
Jim is a Professor of
International Relations
and served as Dean of the
School of International service
at American University
from 2011 to 2017.
He is concurrent with this
library appointment a visiting
Senior Fellow at the
Council on Foreign Relations.
He has held numerous public
policy appointments including
Director for Russian,
Ukrainian and Eurasian Affairs
at the National Security
Council.
Goldgeier has published,
is author of 4 books including
America Between the Wars:
From 11/9 to 9/11, and
Not Whether But When:
The US Decision to Enlarge NATO.
Jim will be available to
you in a range of ways
over the next 8 months on panels
like this as well as informally
through briefings with
committee staff and others.
We're planning events to
give Congress more context
on other forms of
disinformation,
the effectiveness of sanctions
as a foreign policy tool,
why what happened in Russia
happened since the fall
of the Soviet Union
and other topics.
Let me also bring to your
attention our US China Chair,
Minxin Pei, from
Claremont McKenna College,
who will be in residence
beginning
in January for 8 months.
He's one of the world's
foremost experts on China.
He'll be in residence here
for as I said for 8 months.
He'll be heading panels on
the trade war with China,
social control in
China, Chinese advances
in technology and other matters.
A couple of housekeeping things.
We are taping this event.
We may be featuring
it on our website.
When we moved to Q&A after
about 45 minutes or an hour
of presentation by
the panel members,
we will cut off the taping and
so that you guys are not going
to appear on the Library
website asking a question.
So don't worry about that, but
anyway carry on and I'm going
to turn the event
over to Jim Goldgeier.
Welcome, Jim.
[ Applause ]
>> All right.
Come on up.
[ Background talking ]
>> James Goldgeier: Perfect.
Well, thank you all so much
for coming out tonight.
It's great to have such
a range of folks here
from different parts the
congressional staff and it seems
like this was a good topic
to choose to discuss,
and we look forward especially
to your questions and ways
in which we can help you
with your work is what's
most important to us.
So thanks to John Haskell
for his directorship
of the Kluge Center and
thanks to our folks here
from the Carnegie
Corporation of New York.
It's great to see them
supporting the Kluge Center
in this way.
And we've got 3 amazing experts
here tonight who can talk
with us about different
aspects of this issue
of Russian information
manipulation,
their role in US elections and
we're going to talk a little bit
about to compare with
what we saw in 2016
with what we're seeing here
in 2018 and really given that,
you know, we're only a few
weeks out from this election
that we really want to make
sure that we're talking sort
of a the longer-term about the
kinds of things as a country
that we should, can be
thinking about doing
in response to these activities.
So I'm going to open with
some discussions of my own
for the 3 panelists and then,
you know, we do want to move
into a Q&A with you all so
that we make sure that we get,
that we answer the questions
of the people who are going
to be doing the actual
work here.
So the bios are in the folder
but just mentioning
the affiliations.
Dr. Carla Anne Robbins on the
far end, who is both a professor
at Baruch College and
head of the Masters
in International Affairs
Program there as well
as an Adjunct Senior Fellow
at the Council on
Foreign Relations.
Thomas Rid, who is a Professor
at Johns Hopkins
University School
of Advanced International
Studies, and is a great addition
to Washington DC having
come a year ago from the UK.
It's great to have him part
of a very dynamic program
at the Kissinger
Institute at Johns Hopkins.
And Dr. Alina Polyakova,
who is here from the
Brookings Institution
where she works not only
on these issues related
to Russian foreign policy
but also issues related
to populism throughout
Europe, which is, of course,
an incredibly important topic.
So we're going to start
with Carla, who is going
to show us a little bit
about what this information
manipulation actually looks like
and to just give us a sense
of the kinds of things
that people are seeing
that are being produced
by whoever she's
going to tell us
about who's doing
the production.
So, Carla, let's start with you.
>> Carla Anne Robbins: Thank you
so much, Jim, and thank you all.
Great to see you.
So the Russians push out their,
there's a great echo here,
their disinformation on a whole
variety of different platforms
on local language websites as
we know a lot about Facebook
and Twitter and Instagram.
They also have their RT
Television Network and website.
You guys, I don't know
if you spend any time
on RT it's somewhat mind
numbing, but I would suggest
that it definitely gives you
an insight into how they think.
It's Sputnik, they have a, we're
going to look at a few videos
from something they call In
The Now, which is on YouTube
and it's now migrated
over to Twitter,
but these political
technologists tell you,
there are messages for
different audiences,
but certain themes are constant.
Western governments
are weak or unraveling,
elections are rigged,
God-fearing working people are
under siege by migrants,
terrorists
and cosmopolitan interests,
the news from corrupt corporate
mainstream media can't be
trusted and truth
is all relative.
You have your truth, I
have my truth and, yeah,
maybe there were
protesters meeting in Moscow
but what about Ferguson?
They also have this
incredible 21st Century mastery
of what goes viral and as
I said they tailor this
for difficult cultures
and countries.
When I worked at the New York
Times I wish I had understood
to go viral as well as their
to do it although we did it
with the truth and maybe things
that aren't true do better
on viral which is a
very frightening notion
for someone who is a journalist.
The last year they
pushed out on websites
across Central Europe
was story in Polish
that spreading Muslim [phonetic]
culture had led 150,000 women
in Sweden to undergo
female genital mutilation.
Obviously not true.
A story in Czech claiming
that US ships were delivering
migrants to Europe and one
in Russian claiming
Ukraine's health ministry is
selling organs.
And I just chose
those from randomly.
If you want to see what
they're doing every day,
the EU something, called the
EU Disinformation Review,
which you can sign up for.
These things come into my inbox
and you will see just dozens
of stories like this
all the time coming
out on different websites
not just inside of Russia
but across Central
Europe, Eastern Europe
and Western Europe as well.
And they are incredibly
viral and quite compelling.
So what I'm going to show
you here are just 2 videos
from something called
In The Now,
which they've developed
for milennials.
I've chosen them because
they're in English but also
because they're pretty
compelling,
and I can't really tell you, you
know, what their influence is.
Influence is a very
interesting question
and Thomas can tell us
a lot more about this
because he's much more an
expert on it than I am,
but RT which used to
be called Russia Today
until they cleverly rebranded
themselves claims a reach
of 700 million viewers
in 100 countries.
Nielsen does not track them
so we don't really know
how many people watch them
or click on their website.
They have 3.1 million YouTube
subscribers that we know
versus 4.1 million for CNN so
it's a substantial thing but,
you know, most of
their clicks if you go
on their YouTube site are for,
you know, tsunamis in Japan.
I mean they're click bait.
On the other hand, a
little bit goes a long way
when you're talking about viral.
In the 2016 trolling,
$100,000 in Facebook ads,
2,700 Facebook accounts,
80,000 posts reached
126 million Americans.
Slightly fewer than the
number of people who voted.
This question of metrics versus
viral I defer to an expert
like this on this question.
So when you look at the numbers
on these particular videos,
they look reasonably small,
but one of the things
these numbers I'm going
to show you are the numbers
that are RT In The Now numbers.
One of the other things that
I've noticed in looking at some
of these things is they
get picked up not just
by pro-Russia websites
they also get picked
up by alt-right websites
and there is a feedback
that takes place
that's quite interesting
and you can track some of them
and there are some
very interesting people
who are doing very
interesting forensic research
like at the Atlanta Council
and a variety of other places
that see the way things
bounce back and forth
between Russian websites as
well as alt-right websites.
So there's a lot of very
interesting work being done
on this.
So with that I will show
some of our favorites.
Ah, yes, this is how
they describe themselves,
news served hot with
a side of smile.
It sounds so benign.
>> I didn't care
when you got the DNC.
I was fine when you
hacked Clinton's emails,
but this time you've
gone too far, Russia.
You've touched the
most sacred place,
the source of all my funny
vids and friend's baby pictures
and the only reason I
remember my friend's birthday.
>> Russian interference
in the 2016 election
and how it ties to Facebook ads.
>> It sold about $100,000
worth of political ads
to a so-called Russian
troll farm.
>> Yes, it was about helping
Trump and hurting Hilary.
>> Do you want me to
believe that $100,000 worth
of Facebook ads could swing the
US elections trumping Hilary's
campaign, which cost
over a billion dollars?
And then Facebook says 25%
of those ads weren't
even seen by anybody.
And then there's Google who
just last month said it found no
such Russian ads.
Okay, Google, are you sure
there's no Russian interference
on your platforms?
That's better.
You know if Russia
wants to get better
at this then they should
learn from the best, America.
In 1996, Bill Clinton endorsed
a $10 billion loan from the IMF
to Boris Yeltsin which
helped him win the Kremlin
and Russian hearts.
Why? Because he was
completely incompetent
in letting Russia fall apart,
which was exactly why he
was the perfect candidate.
Then Putin came along and
said get the hell out of here,
America, this is our country
but that's another story.
If you really want to
sway an election, Russia,
you've got to do it
the American way.
Learn from the best and have
the balls to spend billions.
What do guys think?
Did these Facebook ads
sway the US elections
and leave us with Trump?
Comment below.
Give me a thumbs
up or thumbs down.
It's up to you.
>> Carla Anne Robbins:
That's Anisa,
the Tokyo Rose of
our generation.
[ Laughter ]
And just one more.
They spent a lot of
time attacking CNN,
attacking the New York Times
because you couldn't possibly
trust the mainstream media
or anything of that sort,
but they also it's not just
about the United States
and Russian influence
in the election; they also
spent a lot of time on Syria
and a variety of other things
and this one has
to do with Syria.
>> Final messages are
flying out of Aleppo, Syria.
They're taking social media
by storm simultaneously.
It almost looks like a
coordinated PR campaign.
[ Inaudible ]
>> This may be my last video.
>> This might be close to if
not the last communication.
>> It's the last time
that I talk to you.
>> It's almost as if they were
hoping these final messages
would trend and get picked
up by mainstream media.
>> [Inaudible] people are
running they don't know where,
just running.
>> We are here living
a genocide literally.
>> People are executed
it's as simple as that.
>> it's almost like these
are just innocent civilians
with no message, no
strategy, no politics,
just people simply
fighting for their lives.
One day saying goodbye
to the world
on social media the next day
giving interviews to BBC,
CNN and Al Jazeera
all in primetime.
Well, they're not.
These are activists.
Some of them just
recently joined Twitter
and clearly support
the revolution.
They have thousands
of followers.
Some call themselves journalists
are verified on Facebook
like Bilal Abdul Kareem,
an American who has no
problem pushing propaganda,
you know, the rebels.
This guy is a member of the
White Helmets who were founded
by a British ex-military
officer and have been funded
with millions by the US and UK
and then there's a
little girl named Bana,
also joined Twitter not
so long ago in September.
She's already verified and
has over 200,000 followers.
Bana is 7 years old and
tweets in perfect English
from the heart of east Aleppo
with a little help
from her mommy.
She, of course, also had a
final message just in time.
So what do all of these
people have in common?
They want you to think
there's one side to this story,
one truth that Oslyn is
randomly going from city to city
and killing his own people for
some crazy reason with the help
of Russia even though the whole
world is watching every step.
They want you to think that
these civilians pouring
out of Aleppo are running
from genocide committed
by the Syrian army and
those who celebrate
on the streets are dancing
on children's graves while
al-Qaeda infiltrated rebels are
bravely and heroically defending
civilians in East Aleppo.
The question is do you buy it?
Because millions of people do.
[ Music ]
>> Carla Anne Robbins:
Do you buy it?
With that.
>> James Goldgeier:
Thanks, Carla.
All right so, Thomas, what do
these things, what do they do
and when we compare
what was done in 2016
and what race concerns
about what was done
in 2016 how does it compare
to what has been done
in this election cycle?
Is it similar in terms
of the type of material,
the scale of it, who
it is targeted to?
If you could just give us
a sense of the evolution
of this type of activity
and what it means.
>> Thomas Rid: Yeah,
I'll be brief.
So what we find in 2016 is
we saw hacking, you know,
dial back remember the
14th of June 2016 is
when this big Washington Post
story broke about the DNC hack,
that the DNC had been hacked and
then one day later on the 15th
of June the first leaks
started appearing first
by this hacker claiming to
be independent [inaudible]
which later turned out to be
Russian Military Intelligence.
Now, we had what we saw with
hacking, I think I need to speak
in this direction here, what
we saw with hacking, sorry,
guys over there, hacking
and leaking just very briefly
the evidence that we had in 2016
that this was going on
was there from day 1.
I remember I was doing a threat
intelligence class literally
on the 15th of June in London
and just a few months prior
to that I was actually at a
Russian security conference
where we learned some tricks of
the trade of malware analysis.
So I applied some of that to the
material that became available
on the 14th of June as did
a lot of people in infosect,
information security,
cyber security community.
And there was no doubt that
this was actually a Russian hack
and when the leak started it
was equally clear to anybody
in the field that this
is a Russian operation.
So one of the failures I
think in hindsight failures
of both the Obama Administration
but really also the intelligence
community was they reacted
so slowly to this
leaking operation
because it was very clear
early on that it was effective,
that it was picked up by the
press and the press treated it
as genuine material
although already
in a very fast leak we
saw traces of messing
with the content of
modifying content,
metadata mainly but still.
Today in 2018 we don't see,
we see a lot of hacking still,
you know, I'm looking here at
a room of high value targets.
I'm not joking, but we
don't see any leaks so far.
So that's a completely
different situation.
What I would also like to
stress that we are not looking
at a general election situation.
It's much harder to interfere
with a mid-term election
because there's no
presidential election going
on at the same time
with the same focus.
So, completely different
ballgame
and I'm deliberately completely
ignoring the social media aspect
right now because I think
it's to be really simplistic
in this room it's blown
out of proportion.
The most important component
of 2016 was the leaking not
the social media amplification.
The operation by the
way was also disjointed.
The social media
Twitter especially
and Facebook the disinformation
component was not synced
up with the leaking.
But let me make this very
personal for a moment
for everybody here in the room.
I'm going to say
something that many
of you wouldn't admit
freely but I have it
from trustworthy sources
that literally everybody
in this room has
a Google account,
maybe also a Slack account.
I'm just assuming here that many
of you use their Google
account sometimes at work.
Right? So let me
ask you let's ignore
that fact whether you use it at
work or not and let's just talk
about your personal Google
account for a moment.
Who in the this room, and we
know hacking is going on, right?
You are high value targets, who
in this room if I can ask you
for a show of hands, who in this
room is using advanced security
settings, you know, 2-factor
authentication, a password
and then something else,
in order to protect a
personal gmail account?
Who is using advanced
security settings?
And just to repeat I'm not
asking you whether you use your
Google at work.
This is not the question
I'm asking.
[Laughter] Are you actually
securing your gmail account
with 2-factor authentication?
And I'm a little shocked at what
I see here is only 1/3 at best.
Those of you who haven't raised
their hands you know what to do
when you get home
and I'm not joking
because it's relatively easy
to break into an email account
if you don't secure it with
2-factor authentication.
And, of course, there
are different ways
to do that securely.
Don't use SMS by the way.
It's not secure.
So keep it simple.
Use an app or even better
Yubico key for the second step,
but really everybody in
this room I just want
to make this very
applied for a moment
in mind should use actually
Google advanced protection and,
you know, we understand
the dynamics here.
Using a personal account
at work is something
that happens everywhere,
it happens here,
it happens in my companies,
I do it too all the time
because my gmail
account is more secure
than my university account.
I'm even using a gmail
account public facing me
because in my line
of work working
with a university email account
has such a bad reputation
because they're so badly
secured that I don't want
to take the reputational risk
of actually using my
employer's email account.
That's how bad the situation is.
It's not much better here, and
I think this is a huge problem
that all parliaments,
all elected, you know,
all democracies are facing
because the security setup,
you know, basically
we're looking
at 435 small business
units in the House
and 100 small business
units slightly larger ones
in the center.
So, you know, fixing security
raises difficult organizational
and ethical issues here.
Do I have another
minute or you want me to?
>> James Goldgeier: Yeah, sure.
One more minute is good.
>> Thomas Rid: Okay.
So let me say something
about leaking side of things.
I spoke about the hacking today.
How about the disinformation
side?
I'm currently finishing
up a book on the history
of disinformation 20th
Century story really,
and what is the goal of
disinformation operations?
What is the logic,
logic of disinformation?
I think it's important to
state that very clearly.
The logic of disinformation
is to undermine the trust
that we have in the
institutions that guard facts
to undermine the trust
in law enforcement
because they only function
on the basis of fact.
So undermine the trust
in the intelligence community
there are also, you know,
analytically keeping facts,
they're writing factual reports,
undermine the authority of
investigative journalism
and really undermine also
the authority of parts
of the public administration
especially election commissions
that are in charge of guarding
the fact at this moment
of grade vulnerability,
that is election night,
because if you can't trust
the facts on election night,
what are you doing to do?
If you can't trust the facts,
you can't trust the press
when you switch on your TV
or when you go to the website
of the New York Times
or something,
if you can't trust the providers
of the facts on election night,
then you will default
to trusting your tribe.
So this is a very unpleasant
truth to articulate here,
but right now the biggest
threat to the integrity
of the election,
the biggest threat
on that very fragile moment
that every democracy is facing
on the evening of election
night, is not Russia.
The biggest threat is that
powerful people and groups
in this country will
call the legitimacy
of the election itself into
question on election night.
Now, when that happens, we're
facing a very dangerous moment
because election night is
also a moment where the peace,
peaceful transition of
power is on the line.
I think, and I really
apologize for sounding so dire
and alarmist here, but I
think and I also apologize
for not looking into
this direction,
but I think in this building
we should really have,
you should really have
conversations, you know,
with your member of Congress
or your senator and nudge them
to have private conversations
about what to do in the heat
of the moment on election
night if shit hits the fan
because it could and if that
happens, then we're looking
at a very dangerous moment and
we have to be ready to face
that moment and not improvise
when it comes to that.
So, because ultimately
the responsibility
to de-escalate will be here,
will be in Congress,
nobody else.
It can't come from
the Executive Branch.
Nobody else will have the
political clout and power
in that moment to fan, you
know, to sort of step forward
and say let's relax
this is what happened,
this is what we should do.
So, yeah, I'd like
to close with that.
>> James Goldgeier: Okay.
So, thank you.
So, Alina, you know,
Carla showed the videos
that are an attempt to sort
of structure the way people are
thinking about particular issues
and Thomas just talked about
the different efforts underway
that can undermine
trust in institutions
and cast doubt on legitimacy.
Is this part of some kind
of coherent Russian strategy
vis-a-vis the United States?
If so, whose strategy is it?
And, you know, how should
we be thinking about sort
of the big picture of what is
going on in the Russian side?
>> Alina Polyankova: Thank
you, Jim, and I'm very lucky
to be following these two
presentations because, one,
I hope I won't be as
dark as Thomas has been
and hopefully I'll combine some
of what you have shown as well.
I think it's important to
remember that, you know,
what Thomas is talking about and
the disinformation activities
of RT and Facebook and
Twitter, et cetera,
don't take place in a vacuum.
There is a much broader
ecosystem here, an ecosystem
of political warfare,
which includes disinformation
campaigns to the [inaudible]
of social media, which includes
cyber attacks and leaks,
which includes then the
amplification of those leaks
and true in the US case
these are not coordinated,
but they do try to
coordinate them
in the French case during
the [inaudible] election,
not successfully.
We can talk a little bit about
why it was not successful,
but they still maybe
have learned
or they should have a better
coordination mechanism there.
And it also includes things
like political influence.
So co-opting individuals,
political parties,
or not [inaudible] just
forging strategic alliances,
for example, with anti-EU,
pro-Russian political parties
in Europe which the Kremlin
has built out a network
of relationships with including
formal cooperation agreements
with at least four of
those political parties.
And it also includes a
thing more importantly money
laundering and elicit finance.
So the buying of influence
in European countries
in the United States through
the export of cryptocracy.
To my mind this is the most
difficult issue to explore
because it's very difficult
to trace those financial
flows unless you're
in the intelligence community
but there's also a lot more
that we can do in the United
States and in Europe to try
to close off some of
those opportunities.
So, we have to look at this as a
basket of tools as an ecosystem.
It's not always so coordinated.
I agree with you there, Thomas,
but then in the grand scheme
of things amplifies the
objectives that Russia is trying
to pursue but it's very obvious
this is not just about Russia.
I mean Russia has pioneered
some of these tools but now
that has shown how effective
these low-cost operations can be
they will clearly and are
clearly already being used
by other hostile foreign actors.
And so the way these
things function the,
so the toolbox I mentioned,
is that they exploit gaps,
they exploit loop holes
in our legal systems
like campaign finances,
campaign finance regulations,
for example, and they exploit
divisions in our society.
I think all of you are
familiar with how that happens
on Facebook by support
through Black [inaudible]
on the one hand and the
white nationalists groups
on the other hand and trying
to coordinate protest movements
and things like that
between these various groups.
I won't go into too
much detail about that,
but I think the bigger point
about a strategic intent is
I do think there's some point
to recognize that what
Russia has done and continues
to do has not been
innovative or sophisticated
from a technical perspective.
They've basically taken the
tools that already existed
out there that corporations
use, the private sector use.
So, like Nike, for example,
would use the same micro
targeting tools on Facebook
or Twitter and Google to
try to sell sneakers to men
between the ages 17 to 19 living
in the suburbs of Michigan
who bought Adidas sneakers
in the last 6 months
and who may have all of
these other attitudinal
demographic characteristics.
These kinds of micro
targeting tools that allow
for not just precision marketing
but also precision
propaganda exists
because there's a
multi-billion dollar industry
because every piece of
content that we see online.
So, in your Facebook feed and
your Twitter feed wherever
and your Google search
what appears first
that is already a
manipulated environment
and the environment is
manipulated not so much
by hostile actors but it's
manipulated by market forces.
And what Russia did in their
operations is they were able
to co-op these tools and what
they're able to achieve is
with very little
money very high impact
and by impact I don't
mean changing the outcome
of the election.
I don't see a lot of evidence
and that's what happened
in the United States given the
low level of Russian engagement.
What I do see is that from
the last 2 years our entire
political system and debate
in conversation has been
completely overtaken by,
we're still talking about it
and for the midterms, you know,
what the Russians did is
Donald Trump, you know,
[inaudible] candidate was,
did Hilary lose legitimately?
We're still talking about
these issues for 2 years
and they're incredibly
divisive to our society.
And so from that perspective
it's been incredibly successful
and high impact at
a very low cost.
So why did the Russians do
this I thing is the question,
why do they continue to do this?
Well, I think we have to
understand what the Kremlin does
from the perspective
of pre-rational actor.
The Russia today faces
quite a significant number
of constraints.
Those constraints being
limited resources.
The Russian economy
is relatively small
and will stagnate for
the foreseeable future.
So it's not China, you know,
the government can't
just snap its fingers
and have an AI strategy
that will invest, you know,
hundreds of billions by 2030.
They can't do that.
They don't have the capacity
for homegrown private
sector innovation.
So they can't compete
with the United States.
Russia attempts to set
up a Silicon Valley have
been pretty much a failure.
This is the [inaudible] they
tried to setup some years ago
which hasn't spurred the kind
of innovation that we see coming
from the United States and
increasingly from China.
And it has a major
human capital problem.
Russia is experiencing
a brain drain.
We don't know a lot
about the details of it
but certainly anecdotally we
know that a lot of individuals
who have tech sector
skills that speak English,
other European languages,
don't have other opportunities
in Russia because the
economy is broken,
there's very little
growth projected
and it's hydrocarbon dependent.
Must like the Soviet
economy was.
So it's very difficult for an
educated young person to be able
to pursue opportunities
there especially they can
go elsewhere.
So, in my view if I'm sitting
in the Kremlin and I'm trying
to think through how to achieve
my broader strategic goal
which is what Thomas said
to undermine the west,
to undermine trust in
democratic institutions,
other institutions underpinning
democracies in the west.
I see them outflanked
militarily,
outflanked economically,
but there are very convenient
targets of opportunity
if we invest in a
symmetric warfare.
And, of course, from a Russian
perspective this has been a long
forming part of Russian military
doctrine warfare isn't just
about tanks or no tanks.
It's a spectrum and information
warfare is very much part
and parcel of that
spectrum and over the course
of the last let's
say maybe since 2006
but still has been accelerated
in 2012 the Russian government
has been investing we don't know
how much obviously and
developing its tool
of asymmetric warfare and this,
again, is a rational strategy
because this is where the
Kremlin can still have
comparative advantage or it
lacks that comparative advantage
in other arenas and at the end
of the day it's a zero sum view
of the world meaning that you
don't have to be a great power,
which is of course
the aspiration
that Putin sees himself
reaching,
the aspiration isn't matched
by reality, but you don't have
to be a really great power.
All you have to do is push
everybody else down so
that your stock rises above
them and that's really the view
of the world and that's
really how I understand all
of these influence
operation and where they fit
in the broader spectrum
of Russian foreign
policy in general.
And so because we're
talking to all of you
who are congressional
staff and you have to think
about what do we do about all
of this not just what is it I
do think there's a few things
that you want to take,
you may want to take
into consideration probably
after the elections are over,
you know, down the line
we are still engaged
in fighting the wars
of yester year.
We still don't know
what to really do
about social media manipulation
of this information.
The US government has not
responded in a coordinated way.
We also don't have the
institutions we used
to have in the Cold War.
So one thing I would say is that
what's coming at us if I'm right
about Russian strategic
investments
in the space is much
more sophisticated tools,
a precision propaganda
disinformation
that will harness the power
of emerging technologies
like artificial intelligence
to be much more precise
and [inaudible] very cheap
[inaudible] these algorithms
they'll all out there
in Open Source.
So the amazing part anybody
can make deep [inaudible],
anybody can manipulate audio,
anybody can manipulate video,
place people's faces, you
know, about all this, right?
I don't have to tell you you
all are like young and part
of the digital revolution
and we're not.
But there are things
that Congress can do.
I think one we haven't
had updated AI strategy
because this is really
the core of the future
of political warfare in my view.
Congress should take a much more
active role in crafting what
that is and potentially seeking
to incorporate more aspects
of a real AI strategy
into the NDAA.
I mentioned elicit finance.
Beneficial ownership legislation
is absolutely key here.
A registry that I think has
proposed multiple bills now
which there is a registry
of beneficial ownership,
find [phonetic] the
ownership that is regulated
and administered by
Fenced In [phonetic].
This would not be public,
which is what it is in the UK
but it would bring up the US
to some level of standards
like the Cayman Islands
potentially not necessarily
with our European
friends and allies.
And this I think
would be an easy fix
and it would go a very long
way in at least blocking some
of those initial loop
holes and gaps that we have
in a regular touring
[phonetic] environment.
So I'll stop with
those two things.
>> James Goldgeier: Great.
Thank you.
Carla, I wanted to just come
back to what you were showing us
at the beginning especially
in the context of what Thomas
and Alina have discussed
with us.
In terms of addressing this
challenge I mean we don't
in this country as a matter of
course seek to regulate content.
And so --
>> Carla Anne Robbins:
-- thank God.
>> James Goldgeier: Right,
so we have a Pulitzer
Prize winning reporter here
but we don't say that
we're going to, you know,
not have this other
voice out there just
because it's spewing
disinformation and isn't
at the same level as
somebody like you.
So, how, so both of those
voices are out there
for the public to choose from.
>> Carla Anne Robbins:
Are you saying
that Anisa is more
persuasive than I am?
>> James Goldgeier: I didn't
say Anisa was more persuasive
than you are, but what do you
do in that type of a situation?
>> Carla Anne Robbins: This
is why it's asymmetric warfare
and that's, you know,
there's no question
that free societies are
soft targets for and one
of the things, listen, Putin
has got a lot of problems
and that's one of the reasons
why he's chosen to do this
but they got something
that we didn't figure out.
They saw our vulnerability
and they saw that there are,
that there's a fundamental
frustration
in developed societies
that they're tapping into.
If there were not more basic
political problems going
on this wouldn't
be so persuasive.
I mean we have to think
about this in greater terms.
This isn't just if we shut
this down this would go away.
There is something
else that we, you know,
to be slightly more optimistic
here Thomas pointed out that we
in the press were much like
the 4-year olds play soccer.
Everybody raced after the
ball during the 2016 election
and didn't say, gee, hmm,
the hacking story itself was
far less an interesting story
than what was in
Hilary's emails.
It was only later that we
all got a little bit smarter
about this.
I believe I think there's
actually quite persuasive proof
that we are capable of learning.
The French elections
we talked about this
in passing the French took a
look at what happened with us
and when they dumped those
9 gigs of information
from [inaudible] hacking
now granted they had a black
out period and we can talk about
there being forensic research
of a variety of things that went
on there, but there was more
of an awareness there.
There's an entire fact-checking
process that's going
on that went on in the
Brazilian elections,
a fact-checking process
in finance that goes
out of the Shorenstein
Center at Harvard.
There's an attempt here
in the press at least,
in the American press and
in the press around world,
to try not to make
that same mistake.
If Thomas is right that the real
problem in 2016 was not Facebook
and Twitter and I'm not saying
that he was right or wrong
on this, the real problem
was that the press all raced
to that one story itself
I think we're smarter
and I think we have more
self-awareness on it,
but I think we have
to be vigilant.
Editors have to be vigilant,
reports have to be vigilant
and we have to learn, we have
to be aware of these things.
I know Thomas is not
going to agree with me.
He doesn't think we're capable
of learning, but I would argue,
I would argue that we
are more self-aware
and there's certainly
a huge effort
across the journalism community
not just in this country
by across the world
to use a variety
of tools including crowd sourced
information to do fact-checking
and make sure this
stuff doesn't take off.
Now, does that mean that
people are not going to believe
in their Facebook feed?
That the Pope endorsed
Donald Trump?
There will be people
who believe that,
but I think that next time
something is hacked we're not
going to behave like 4 year olds
going after the soccer ball.
>> Thomas Rid: Can
I respond to this?
>> Carla Anne Robbins: Sure.
>> James Goldgeier: Please.
>> Thomas Rid: I
mean I do believe
that we are capable of learning.
After all I'm, my business is
teaching so to a degree I have
to believe in learning.
>> Carla Anne Robbins: I
meant we as journalists.
>> Thomas Rid: Oh, still
I even teach journalists.
So the, but the problem
is a little more complex
than that obviously
because have you,
and this is a genuine question,
have we see that [inaudible]
moment in American journalism,
you know, that is
comparable to what happened
after the Iraq invasion?
What I see is and saw
to an extent still see is
a really impressive amount
of self-righteousness in
covering Facebook and Twitter,
Facebook more than
Twitter for reasons
that I really don't understand.
Pointing the finger at
social media companies
with a certain feel good
attitude behind the off the
record phase of the conversation
I feel I can make it a little
more lively.
>> Carla Anne Robbins:
We're actually not
yet in the off the record
phase but please go on.
[Laughter]
>> Thomas Rid: Fair enough.
>> Carla Anne Robbins: As if
anything can be off the record
with 150 people in the
room, but please do go on.
>> Thomas Rid: As in not
on the website later
on, but fair enough.
So, I mean the point
is that, you know,
take the Podesta leaks everyday
of October 2016 we had one,
you know, we had one leak coming
out actually a little more
than one per day and it was
just exasperating to watch how
like Pavlov's dogs, you know,
conditioned to follow the stick.
At that level it was
not a secret anymore
that influence operation was
underway of major proportions.
That was really depressing
to watch, but I didn't want
to relitigate the past.
>> Carla Anne Robbins: Okay, I
believe and I think if you look
at the fact-checking exercises
that have been set up,
which have been done
with consortiums
of newspapers this is,
I'm not going to comment
on the self-righteousness
of journalists
versus the self-righteousness
of academics given the fact
that I'm both, but certainly
if you look at the effort
that has been made in
subsequent elections
to do fact-checking exercises
certainly there is a very strong
sense of awareness of the
dangers that are out there
and the desire not to fall
into a trap whether there has
been a transcendent mea culpa
moment of the level that you
want the media is not one
big blob.
There's many different news
organizations but I would say
that these fact checking
exercises shows and awareness
that they, that we don't
want to get fooled again.
>> Thomas Rid: Agreeing is
boring for the audience.
>> James Goldgeier: I have one
question for Alina following
up on her presentation and
then we're going to open it up.
We're going to turn
off the cameras
and we'll get your questions.
So you mentioned the need
to update the AI strategy
and incorporating that into the
next NDAA and I'm just wondering
if you could just say a couple
of words about the types
of things you think need
to be done in that regard?
>> Alina Polyankova: I did
forget to mention one thing
that I think is worth
thinking about.
I mentioned the online
advertising industry
which is now basically
the wild, wild west.
It's completely unregulated.
One reason for that is
because social media
in the private sector space
has been completely unregulated
as well reminds me of
the days of tobacco.
This is going to be a
controversial example comparing
Facebook, Twitter and Google
to big tobacco in the 1950s,
but I think what we're
talking about at the end
of the day is how do you affect
behavioral change among people?
And it is possible
through a combination
of regulation civil
society activism,
new institutions being
built and awareness raising.
So you know how do
we go from 1950s
when big tobacco was also
completely unregulated
completely and, in
fact, you know,
pregnant women are recommended
that they should smoke
for smooth delivery.
So how did we go from that
to smoking essentially
being outlawed?
I mean essentially illegal
in the United States
and most places.
We took a combination
of Congressional action
to a combination of messages
coming from trusted sources,
which is again goes back to
this question of the key crux
of our democratic
institutions are norms
and if you don't
have a trusted source
and the Surgeon General
was a trusted source
in the tobacco example, how
can you actually get people
to believe anything?
And that's why the attacks we've
all been describing have been
targeting this one
specific area.
And, of course, it took a lot
of public awareness
campaigns and lots of money.
At the end of the day
things like labeling
on cigarettes also didn't
work just like labeling
on certain content on
social media doesn't work.
In fact, Facebook
did a quick beta test
of labeling disputed content
and guess what people
clicked on it more.
Right? Because we human
psychology makes us want to look
at train wrecks and it makes us
want to look at that, you know,
hidden, dirty, sexy stuff,
you know, we're not supposed
to be looking at and some things
[inaudible] bad I don't want
to look at it.
So I think the question to
all of us is how do you get,
how do you think about messaging
some reason reject automatically
because people don't
respond well.
They have a strongly held belief
and you present them with facts
that counter that belief
it doesn't actually matter.
People actually double down
in their belief, right?
And there's a lot of
social psychology research
that shows this.
I think we're still having
this conversation I'm talking
about the wars of yester year.
So the wars of the future which
is what you actually asked me
about and AI issues,
you know, one,
a lot of this work is happening
in the classified space
and we don't know about it.
At least I don't know
about it, and I accept
that so there may
be things happening.
My sense is that most of what's
probably happening has a very
clear military dimensions
about swarm technology
and [inaudible] technologies
and things like that.
We need to understand
what is the range
of US government
research and development
and artificial intelligence
across all the agencies
not just DoD?
Can we have a classified
assessment of that?
It has to be classified.
Where are we investing?
And if there is an
attack of this nature,
they utilize these
new technologies
like [inaudible] generated
out of serial networks,
which is what produces these
deep [inaudible] how do we set
up a system of metrics
to respond?
We don't have processes
or mechanisms,
there's no inner agency
process that I know
about that would get the
US government to turn
on when there's a response
needed or not to respond
when there's no response
needed, right?
So we need to be thinking
about resources, about,
I'm just thinking
implications not
in just the military space
public diplomacy, for example,
absolutely critical,
State Department, DHS,
we have the capacity and the
tools but we're not thinking
about the next piece and that's
really what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about
the implications
of artificial intelligence.
It's not just about the
shifts in our economy
and what jobs will be lost
and jobs will be gained,
these are [inaudible]
technologies at the end
of the day and they can be
used for good and evil just
like Facebook or
Twitter as we found out.
>> James Goldgeier:
Great, thanks.
Well, I do want to open
it up and so we'll move
on to the unrecorded
part of this session
so that you can ask
whatever questions.